the jurgen experience the course of a
lot of these drugs and how they hit
market is super interesting i've been
learning more and more about this
because one of my colleagues who works
on aggression and mating behavior which
fascinates me
has identified some peptides that can
really reduce anxiety they put these to
the pharmaceutical industry
pharmaceutical wasn't interested in them
at all even though the safety margins
are huge so you say why why wouldn't
they want this well turns out these same
drugs failed in a schizophrenia trial a
long time ago so no one will go near it
with a 10 foot pole so what the way the
pharmaceutical industry generally
approaches drugs is
they love to remarket drugs for which
there's already fda approval because
then they don't have to go through all
the safety stuff
and when they do that they can renew the
patent this is crucial right because if
you can get the generic version now with
things like goodrx and these like little
apps you can get them you can go into a
pharmacy you hit goodrx and it'll say oh
yeah we've got some stuff that's about
to expire this 300 a month drug is ten
dollars i've had this happen it's you
know amazing if they can keep it out of
the generic market
that's huge and the way to do that is to
find a new clinical use so
i don't know which one came first
narcolepsy or these these focusing adhd
uses but or as a performance enhancer
but if the
pharmaceutical industry the people that
own the patent to that drug can find a
new legitimate use they just bought
themselves i think another 10 years on
the
on the patent so this was originally
prescribed for schizophrenia and then
they were going to use these peptides
for mating
yeah so here so in terms of the
aggression this is really interesting
this is the work of a guy at caltech
named david anderson and he works on
mating and aggression and the
relationship human beings in well he has
work related to humans and the
neighboring lab works on humans but in
mice and in humans but these areas of
the brain are really conserved this this
we can talk about which brain area but
what he discovered is observed meaning
um sorry that in mice and in humans
these brain structures look identical
and that the same classes of neurons
exist that if you were to stimulate them
because neurosurgeons have done this
people go into a rage or in animals if
you stimulate them the animals go into a
rage in fact there are these videos
online they're incredible where this is
diulin's work when she was in david
anderson's lab so you take two mice a
male mouse and female mouse and they're
mating right as it were and then they
stimulate these neurons because they can
do that now in a you know using light
believe it or not
and those and the male immediately tries
to kill the female
you can even just put him in a cage
alone with a glove filled with air
he's walking around you stimulate these
neurons and he just goes into a rage
right just just trying to destroy this
glove but here's what's super
interesting and no one understands if
you put this animal into a cage alone
and stimulate
it looks pretty normal it doesn't do
anything so it's not like it attacks
itself and you know and every time
there's this you know horrible news
event like the school shooting thing or
something like that i always think you
know like what's going on in the there's
a certain brain here it's called the
ventromedial hypothalamus this is a
brain area that's really interesting
because it has a population of neurons
that control mating you stimulate them
and animals will just start trying to
copulate with basically whatever's
around if you give them a choice of
their usual
preference of you know females if
they're male
males if they're female because that's
the way my mice go
one or the other they will just try and
start mating you stimulate the other
group of neurons and they will try and
kill the other mouse is so these are
like switches in the hypothalamus i mean
are these like very distinct like when
you we talk about like neurons and
switches like how do you distinguish
between the one can you see them like
what is the difference great question so
for many decades it was known that if
you stimulate this brain area you could
get aggression this is actually nobel
prize winning work of a guy named whose
last name is hess
and
what they found was if you stimulate
this brain area cats would go into
either two kinds of of aggression it was
either defensive aggression kind of with
with you know hair up right or you would
stimulate a little bit more and they
would do the you know predatory
aggression right i'm probably doing this
wrong but you know like ears forward and
you know you're you're the hunter last
time i'm still learning about you know
animal behavior in this way
but what's really interesting is that
for years no one could understand why if
you also stimulated this brain area and
you used a different pattern of
stimulation you get mating behavior and
it turns out that the neurons are mixed
in there like salt and pepper
david anderson's lab
figured out that these are molecularly
distinct neurons and what makes them
distinct is really interesting if they
stimulate only the neurons that have the
estrogen receptor
they become aggressive and this again
goes back to this thing that we talked
about a while ago which is that
testosterone
aromatized converted into estrogen has
these incredible effects on aggression
and masculinization of the brain and a
lot of people think
in fact people heard me say that last
time and said oh you're trying to say
that estrogen is doing everything
testosterone is doing no it's that
things like testosterone and estrogen
control gene expression and so the fact
that it's estrogen or testosterone it
doesn't really matter it's the fact that
these are molecularly distinct neurons
they can trigger these neurons and they
can get very distinct outputs of
behavior but what's crazy is you stop
stimulating the animal just goes back to
doing whatever and then goes oh man i
think i'll try and mate again now
eventually the female's like hey this is
getting confusing
but
this
it's clear that these sorts of things
are also happening in humans but
normally we have kind of a weighting of
aggression versus mating behavior right
some people choose to combine those
right there's kind of extremes of that
rape there's rough sex there's all sorts
of you know it's it's uncomfortable for
people to think about that but there's a
continuum between a aggressive versus
approach type behaviors and for whatever
reason this drove me to start looking at
different mating behaviors of animals
online like if you watch ferrets mating
it's like he's biting the back of her
neck she's squealing all over the place
like this is uncomfortable for some
people see some people probably like
watching this stuff but
you look at animals mating and there's a
kind of a
a balancing act between you know what
looks it's not you wouldn't call it love
making let's put it that you'd call it
mating that's pretty aggressive and
that's very common in the animal kingdom
so is it coming in the animal kingdom
because
for in order to
have strong genes that pass on
you need a strong animal and so they
express themselves in this aggressive
way to prove to the female that they're
strong enough to mate and and procreate
like what is the reason
for for that sort of aggressive is there
a reason well it's a great question so
there's this theory called hydraulic
pressure theory this was developed by
conrad lorenz which is another nobel
prize winner who studied animal behavior
and here's the idea is that all of these
just different populations of neurons
are in the hypothalamus this is a little
tiny tiny thing i mean it's the size of
like a little gobstopper candy like a
little gumball and you've got neurons
for aggression neurons for mating
neurons that turn on to make sure that
you that animals don't try and mate with
the wrong species right we take this for
granted like how come a cat doesn't try
and mate with the dog no the dog might
hump but that's a different thing
altogether so it's all harbored in there
and this hydraulic theory is that
all of these things are kind of
weighted probabilities so there's never
zero probability that any of this will
happen unless they're in sleep but maybe
it's 10 aggression
80 mating while they're mating maybe
another male enters the arena and now
they're sort of like the confusion like
am i gonna have to fight or can i keep
mating these kinds of things because
oftentimes these animals are communal
in some way
and so the way that anderson explained
this to me and we had a conversation
about this recently is that the brain
might actually get confused in certain
moments that you know and there's also a
kind of opioid pain relief thing that
gets released during sexual activity
pain threshold goes way up right and we
were talking about this in the context
of fetishes because you know if you look
at fetishes they're not random true
fetishes are like can be pathologies
where people actually require the
presence of something in order to become
aroused and those things almost always
if you look at true fetishes are things
like
feet
dead bodies feces animals things that
are all very
infectious exactly your facial
expression illustrates it perfectly my
facial expression for those listening is
yuck exactly
so
you know
that's disgust and you have circuits in
your brain that are for discuss that are
about getting you away from that thing
because it's infectious putrid
disgusting and out of context
and then you think about sex and food
appetite and all that and it's it's all
repetitive as they call it it's moving
towards it it's bringing in more of
those molecules as opposed to trying to
get away from like vomiting right but
the feet thing isn't like guys like
pretty feet it you know we're very
visual animals and so it may cross over
into visual perception and what arouses
people differs obviously people have
their different proclivities but
true fetishes are a kind of a confusion
of this circuitry right where people
confuse or learn arousal associated with
something that's actually quite
dangerous i mean you take the extreme
one like dead body it's like incredible
is that normal no no no no no excuse me
not normal
like the dead body one
not common not common common enough that
you brought it up though well i've been
reading up on this because i'm i'm
fascinated by the primitive as a in
addition to the more evolved parts of
the brain
so the way anderson describes is you
know you'll see animals mating and then
all of a sudden you know he'll bite the
back of her neck or sometimes she'll
bite him
and the theory is that some of the
neurons and they've seen this in brain
imaging in real time because they can do
that in animals some of the neurons that
are responsible for aggression will just
suddenly you know spike up there right
and and will kind of overtake the other
behavior and then they'll go back to
mating
now when you're
talking about studies on animals and
they're doing this it's kind that there
there's these ethical questions if
you're going to do a study on humans if
you wanted to stimulate those same
neurons and try to incite aggression
or hostility or even arousal but has
anybody done it they have they have they
have so a good friend of mine eddie
chang he's the chair of neurosurgery at
ucsf he's
spends his life and he makes his living
probing around in the brain of people
who have epilepsy looking for the site
where if they stimulate the person will
have a seizure so they can burn that
area out or make some other manipulation
and he's told me that he's been poking
you can't poke around at random right
you can't you know every scientist would
love to just do that experiment just go
in and kind of search but there are
sites where they'll stimulate
thinking they might evoke a feeling of
pleasantness or no feeling at all and
the person will go into a rage in the in
the or in the operating room because
they're wide awake you've probably seen
these things of people with neurosurgery
and they're playing the violin or things
of that sort
occasionally they'll hit an area where
the person will say i'm feeling super
angry right now and they'll say let's
back off a little bit from there and
they'll chart where they were in the
brain that is wild so there's just like
a spot yeah there is and we have
switches right i mean we have switches
for rage switches for all these things i
mean that's like the psychologist carl
jung you know this idea that we have all
things inside of us i mean
people vary in their
propensity for rage or for
love or for anything but
at some level we do have all things
inside of us we have the circuitry
within us and do you think that feel
like that variation is neurochemical
that there's i think it is neurochemical
and i think it is learned as well this
peptide that we were talking about
earlier becomes relevant in in this
context so david's lab discovered
there's a peptide called tachykinin it's
related to another molecule that's
involved in pain relief called substance
p that we all make tachykinin has a
bunch of different forms but in humans
there's tachycardia one and tachycon in
two
in mice or humans that are socially
isolated for a period of time
tachycardia levels go through the roof
this is very relevant to the recent past
around the pandemic in my opinion
it goes through the roof and what
happens it creates anxiety anger and in
particular aggression
and so there are drugs that are
tachycardian inhibitors
and i asked david i said well why aren't
we giving tachycardia inhibitors to
people that are feeling anxious and and
aggressive and you know kind of tamp
that down and we just had yet another
school shooting and we could talk about
what that's about but or not but and he
said this drug is actually approved it's
very safe when you stop what do you say
what are you saying there's a drug that
can understand but you're saying
what that's about but we're not oh sorry
the the
the tacky kind and i mean is was it
elevated and for instance the kid that
went in and shot all those kids and how
could they find that out post-mortem i
think they could do what's called mrna
and situ hybridization they could see
how much of the gene for tachycardia was
being made i think they should do
postmortem i don't know how he was
killed if his brain is still intact um i
think like most people there's very
little concern about him and more
concerned about the victims as it should
be but
just like with ct and football players
you want to know where the damage was
and also whether or not there was a
brain thing there and if that brain
thing was there it doesn't mean
necessarily that he was born with a bad
brain he might have been born with a
dysfunctional brain but social isolation
increases anxiety and aggression there's
no question and actually i was in social
isolation increases aggression
absolutely really absolutely feelings of
aggression and kind of friction with the
world us them kind of thinking
okay i was in new york uh this is a few
months back and it was it was the most
eerie experience because we were there
recording some podcasts and
something came over the news that you
know there was literally killer loose
and it was that guy in brooklyn went
into a subway released some smoke bombs
and shot people right
they found him in the lower east side
walking around someone found so like
killer on the loose in new york became a
real thing for the time we were there it
was super weird because we're staying
down near the lower east side
and they get the guy and what do they
say they say the same thing they always
say about these guys he was a loner he
was really socially isolated then you
find the angry posts you find the things
online but it's never like oh this okay
you've got crazies like the btk killer
and people who are like in their church
and stuff but we're so you know
sociopathic killers on on the sly but
these kind of random at what seemed like
random acts of aggression almost always
these people were highly socially
isolated which and i'm not evoking
sympathy i want to be very clear
you know i mean nothing makes me more i
think everyone is furious and frustrated
about this situation with the shooting
but i asked david about this i was like
why aren't these drugs being used or
prescribed and he said because years ago
there was a trial at a pharmaceutical
company exploring the role of this drug
in schizophrenia for reasons that aren't
clear and it didn't work and it cost the
company a ton of money so now no
companies want to go near it there's
this kind of you know black listing of
drugs that failed in trials and as a
consequence there's probably dozens if
not hundreds of very useful medications
out there that are just not being
explored